good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Friday wow it is so exciting I've
never needed a Friday more in the queue
hey Claude how you doin I'm good it
doesn't even feel like a Friday like the
the difference between the weekends and
the weekdays is getting more and more
blurred I didn't even realize it was
Friday until you literally just said
that um but I want to show you something
like kind of crazy oh my god please do
ready yet yeah I'm scared you're
drinking coffee I'm drinking coffee what
to what do we owe this pleasure I don't
know I just I need to like you said like
taking a showers like a different state
of being I just need something different
like my days have gotten more and more
monotonous and boring and I don't know I
thought maybe like I'll have diarrhea or
something it'll at least be something
exciting yeah Wow I'm really excited to
see what kind of coffee are you drinking
Ethan I feel like you would hate the
taste like I love coffee but I don't
even like how it tastes no I don't like
the taste but Ben has la Colome
something and then like some hazel
murmur yeah yeah that creamer so it's
not exactly healthy but like I don't
really care
no that's not that's not bad creamer
like sounds a lot worse than it is but
you don't use that much because it's so
creamy so and it's sugary and if it
makes a big difference in your taste of
your coffee then it's worth it I'm just
interested in coffee today too because I
ran out of some of my cold boot
concentrate so we have like these
Starbucks things in our house
but I like put it over ice with milk and
it's actually pretty good
okay that's where I'm at I wonder if
your like behavior on the show today is
gonna be different because you're all
caffeinated well I'm feeling very
jittery but like last night from like 7
o'clock on I was having the worst
anxiety like I couldn't even pinpoint
what it was about I was just like in my
bed like wanting to just do like a
million things and I was just feeling so
anxious like all the bad things I feel
about myself and my life were just like
at the forefront of my brain I couldn't
turn it off it was so frustrating so I
might just be like feeling the excess of
that or it's the coffee I don't know
we'll say interesting okay well sorry
about that um it was terrible and I was
trying to explain
to been like why I was so anxious and he
was just like what's wrong and it's like
when you're anxious if you don't know
what's wrong so right there's no rhyme
or reason it's not logical all the time
Oh Sofia what was so frustrating is like
I was like trying to explain I'm just
like I don't know I've just been feeling
like so on edge like I keep reading like
stuff about me and like it makes me so
upset and he's like no I mean like you
don't anything to worry about it's gonna
be fine and I'm like but how do you know
that like it was the most frustrating
response he's like he's like no no
nobody feels that way I'm like what they
do like I'm seeing people writing me
things about me let me know they feel
that way so it's like he was just like
invalidating my feelings I was getting
so annoyed that it actually made me so
annoyed I fell asleep which was a
blessing great I'm so glad to hear that
I did something really special last
night and I restarted Ugly Betty it is
the whole series is available on Hulu
and Wow like I watched the whole series
growing up I can't believe it's from
2006 we were so young then that is crazy
but we used to watch it every week and
so obviously I know all the characters
but as far as the storylines go I
remember some of the big ones but like
I'm watching this show with fresh eyes
it is so current and perfect and
amazingly well done if anybody is
looking for a show to watch like it's up
there with Desperate Housewives which
just goes to show that Vanessa Williams
is the common denominator and she is
just like so iconic she's also in the
Hannah Montana would be like her catalog
is impeccable oh that's so true I mean
that era at ABC with like all these like
overdramatize like not soap operas but
not just regular TV shows which was
desperate housewives and Ugly Betty was
like a fantastic time to be at like a
teenager I recently watched like the
first two seasons of Ugly Betty and then
I'm just like kind of fell off but the
first season is good it's just like so
sad they were so mean to Betty at the
company and like nobody respected her
and they were pranking her and even
though like I ended up loving Amanda and
Marc that first season they were like
unbearable
it's brutal I'm watching with Snitch we
started at the same time and we're just
like texting each other like hit tears
like when Betty's crying in the bathroom
like it's so brutal I never realized how
hard she had it like oh my god and you
know what usually the protagonist of
your old favorite show you come to hate
but Betty is such a queen like she's so
selfless she's so cute
I just want the best for her she worked
so hard she was like so proud of her
family and her culture and like when she
showed up that first day wearing a
poncho like I lived for that I lit I
live for her and when she showed up on
Halloween as a butterfly but no one else
dressed up like she could have easily
taken her wings off and then just walked
around in this weird ugly dress but no
she went full stop all day because she
loves Halloween like no one's gonna stop
her from being herself no matter how
badly she thinks she wants to fit in so
for our TV recap segment let's talk
about that also yesterday we forgot to
talk about High School Musical 3 which I
watched the day before yesterday and I
started Hollywood and I have some
thoughts okay cool don't spoil anything
for Hollywood we'll get more when we get
to our TV recap segment before we do any
of that I think it's time wow really I'm
actually wearing a watch today so I can
tell you that it is time for the Fast
Five story is that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and that's true Jackie but on the
subject of anxiety I would like to talk
about today's sponsor the freedom debt
solutions the anxiety and stress caused
by debt is overwhelming it makes you
feel alone and like there's no way out
especially now but there is a way out
you don't have to go through it alone
and Freedom Debt Solutions is here to
help there is no one-size-fits-all
solution to getting out of debt Freedom
Debt Solutions has more than 400 debt
experts standing by to recommend the
right solution for your specific
situation no matter which solution you
may qualify for freedom debt solutions
could help you get rid of expensive
credit debt faster than you can on your
own with one low affordable monthly
program payment since 2002 Freedom Debt
Solutions has served over 750,000
clients settled over 2.7 million
accounts and settled over 10 million
dollars in debt so if you have $10,000
or more in credit card debt and you're
struggling to make monthly payments
there is hope stop the stress and
anxiety your debt is causing find out
how you can talk to a freedom debt
solutions expert and get your free
personalized debt consultation today
go to freedom debt solutions calm /
toast that's freedom
debt solutions dot-com / toast freedom
debt solutions calm / toast and get
yourself out of debt because nobody
needs that anxiety and stress it's
already at like an anxious and enough
world ok first story there
exciting news Taylor Swift announces a
concert special after canceling lover
fest due to the corona virus pandemic so
Taylor Swift city of lover will air on
May 17th at 10:00 p.m. Eastern time line
on ABC and will be available on demand
on Hulu and Disney plus the following
day the footage is from a concert that
was filmed last September at lil Olympia
theater in Paris while Swift was
promoting her latest studio album at the
time an intimate group of fans from 37
countries flew into Paris for the
concert where the singer performed songs
off lover where's everybody but in
exciting Taylor Swift's tan what does
this news do for you well it's very
exciting because this is the first and
only time she's performed some of the
songs from lover the album so it is my
understanding that she's saying London
boy death by a thousand cuts of course
like me lover um but it's just very
exciting first of all like we love
content we love content and - we love
Taylor Swift content especially
never-before-seen and it's just very
exciting to be a Taylor Swift fan this
morning like I love just waking up to
little surprises a lot of people were
expecting some sort of announcement
today because five eight has become like
a number it adds up to 13 she posted an
Instagram post last week at 5:08 p.m.
and a lot of people were thinking that
she was gonna release a single off the
album cruel summer um but I guess that's
not what it turned into but it's just as
good of an action for an announcement
this is a cruel summer that's the single
if I ever heard of one big time but I
just love that like as Swifties we're
constantly just like throwing [__]
against the wall and we were right about
something so it feels good to be right
yeah I love this mostly because as much
as I appreciate all the at home content
that artists are putting out to get a
real high def production right now is so
exciting I am I loved the album and I'm
very much looking forward to watching
this on may 17th and speaking of a high
production value I haven't seen a lot of
promotion for it but Amazon Prime did a
concert of Maren Morris's girl tour in
Chicago and it came out like this week I
mean I haven't seen a lot promotion
about it I saw it on meirin's Instagram
but I will most certainly be watching on
Oh amazing I still need to
also Jonas Brothers happiness I'm just
waiting for the vibe you know and I
don't know I don't know where that's
gonna come from so I think I watched it
in a negative vibe because I didn't love
it like I loved the documentary and
something about this concert I usually
don't like when they take a concert and
they keep splicing it up with like
behind the scenes content like when we
kept um home coming by Beyonce
I actually liked that behind the scenes
stuff because it gave a lot of context
and a lot of knowledge about like the
theme homecoming HBCUs like that I
appreciate it but with this Jonas
Brothers thing they were adding it was
almost like footage that didn't make the
documentary they were splicing it up
between songs and it was just really
really frustrating except like I said
Joe Jonas number one fan that I am I did
like live for um
hearts about him he was like I hate
working out I would never work out but I
just like love to run and dance on stage
and it's like I just get so crazy and I
can't be getting out of breath he's like
you think I want to on the treadmill no
it's like that stuff was interesting and
he like it's always riding his bike but
other than that um it just made me a
little sad because nobody respects Kevin
and like he was just when they would
like put them in a room together and
make them talk like about their feelings
or whatever and no one would listen to
him like he would say something
incredibly profound and it would be dead
silent and then Nick is like yeah that's
good advice
it's like he's older and wiser and like
just [__] respect him and it was
taking himself so seriously like he
really just wants like it out there that
he is like the talent he is the
songwriter he is a musician he made us
like watch him sing in a shower because
he sang in the shower the last time they
were out the menu when they were 15 so I
was not living for the behind-the-scenes
but they gave us a lot of like Sophie
Priyanka Danielle content which was good
and the concert was great like the
filming was good um I just could've
dealt without some of the in-between
stuff
nice okay I'll watch it but it's not
something I want to watch when I'm like
laying in bed I need to be doing kind of
something else maybe I'll do it while
I'm doing my nails or something like
that way I'm half in half out okay cool
I'm gonna do my nails today I'm really
excited I can't even tell you how much
like this has become one of my new
favorite hobbies I want to start doing
like other people's nails too like yours
mostly I mean my nails are absolutely
disgusting but they're strong and
they're growing and I feel like
whenever in my life am I gonna be able
to not have a manicure for three months
mm-hmm honestly my nails feel less
strong when I have nothing on them they
like hurt almost um but you got to get
this nail teks clear polish up told me
about it right yeah a million times and
I need it my nails are so brittle like I
will open the fridge and break a nail oh
my god I know for sure for its torture
it's like my nails are in as poor of
health as I am yet honestly the nails
really are representation like do you
have enough iron do you have enough
biotin do you have enough calcium
totally it's like if you're not eating
vegetables your nails are brittle and
that's why mine are brittle yeah okay
this next door is another Taylor Swift
story it's just a big Taylor Swift day
because fans are convinced that Taylor
Swift and Katy Perry are collaborating
thanks to a sweater okay Katy Perry
announced so Taylor Swift posted her
photo yesterday on her couch by the way
her caption was iconic big isolation
isolation big isolation you and me you
got a big isolation ah and I heard of
that oh and you know what that song a
lot of people think is about like her
beefs with other celebrities and it
could be that that song has a little
something to do with Katy Perry so
that's interesting I'm just gonna take
the caption to be like she's been
obviously in her house you know we may
come up songs look at your husband like
writing a song every week like she's
making her songs applicable to the
quarantine and so she just wanted to
like share that interesting factoid with
the class um but so she's wearing a
daisy sweater in the photo and Katy
Perry just put out single artwork for a
song called daisies so Katy Perry
announced her new song daisies on
Thursday and shared a peek at the tracks
artwork and in which the singer basks in
a field of flowers the first single from
perry's upcoming fifth studio album
daisies is set to drop on May 15th the
music must go on she wrote on Instagram
oh wow new Katy Perry exciting I feel
like this era is gonna be good I just I
don't know why I feel that I did it's
because of the Bibbit inside of her is
giving her this like courage this spark
this maternal vibe that I think is gonna
come through in the music I think yeah
and she she really said song never worn
white when she announced her pregnancy
and it was so beautiful so I don't know
I'm just I'm loving this new like
American Idol Katy Perry vibe I just
feel like she has so much happiness and
energy and I look forward to that
exerting in her music I think like her
sitting in between Lionel Richie icon
Luke Bryan like life of the party I
think they're really like giving her
this energy that she's needed over the
last few years like she had a couple
dark years I'm not gonna lie um but I
really think American Idol did great
things obviously for her career but also
for her spirit ya know I think I think
overall it's been really good
also we never talked about but I think
was when my friends mentioned to me when
we recapped her song amber born white
because you know she's never been
married
um she was married to Russell Brand of
course who could forget that iconic
documentary part of me where we really
live but we legit for God like we had a
whole conversation about her and we
didn't even remember for one second I
mean that was a lifetime ago and when
they were together I actually thought
they were perfect together but Russell
Brand is strange like he really fell off
the face of the earth but also has a
podcast so I guess that's just what
people do these days like us um anyways
later that same day Swift posted a rare
selfie while sipping wine on her couch
at home clad in a floral sweater
free people like we love a sponsored
moment no I don't think was sponsored
but it did sell out considering Swift's
penchant for dropping Clues before
releasing any music or videos Swift's
Swifty's immediately began speculating
about a possible team-up with Perry with
many pointing out this week marks the
two-year anniversary of the pair's
reconciliation following their lengthy
feud Wow yes you know what those days
with these Leduc Taylor swept Easter egg
things it's like you read the evidence
and you are 100% convinced and to me
this is like this doesn't even seem like
they're trying to hide it like to me
this evidence is so obvious but I felt
this way so many times when like going
down rabbit holes of Easter eggs that
she's dropping and sometimes they never
come true so it's very possible that
this is happening honestly you just
really really convinced me um but it's
also possible like we are just so bored
and we're stewing in our houses so we'll
see I mean it would be fabulous I loved
their collab the last time but they
weren't actually singing together it was
just you need to calm down
but this would be great okay as someone
who's a little bit more zoomed out and
you know when like it comes to the
Taylor Swift DaVinci Code I have no time
for the clues I'm reading this and like
Taylor Swift hasn't posted a lot of like
quarantine content of her in isolation
alone and this fan tweeted Taylor just
happens to post a pic of herself in a
daisy sweater the same day Katy
announces her new single called daisies
when it comes to Taylor Swift
this is Jackie oh speaking not the
Twitter there's no coincidences only
thing I'll say is that maybe she did it
to be supportive another fan suggested
that what if it's a song that Taylor
wrote for Katy Perry that's a good
theory but Katy Perry is an incredible
songwriter why with her first single off
her new album actually I mean
songwriters it's possible yeah it's
possible you know what I would love to
see Taylor Swift on an episode of song
land like she to me is the
quintessential songwriter but it's
obvious that she has this like big deal
with ABC because in the last year she's
been doing only really ABC like GMA um
now it's on Hulu and Disney Plus like
she obviously has some sort of
partnership so I don't think she
actually could go on song land um but I
would love to see her there are you
caught up on song land no I missed the
her episode and Martina McBride but it's
I totally forgot about it until now I
need to watch okay I'm totally caught up
to her episode was so good the I won't
spoil about the person who wins because
if I tell you too much about her then
you'll know when you're watching the
episode but Amy's creamy no no I know
it's a her I know it's a her um no and
then Martina McBride um also really good
and really surprising and I'm so annoyed
okay if anybody from song land listen to
this podcast you use you guys used to
have the songwriters record the song
that they wrote even if it wasn't chosen
and we could just listen to it on
Spotify but they're not doing that
anymore only the song that wins gets
recorded by the artist like there's so
many songs that I've been loving like
honestly if I was an artist I would call
up and pick up all the scrap songs that
people aren't choosing totally like some
of the music that gets made these days
is so trashy that like there's obviously
a drought for like premium songwriters
and song land has this ability to just
like all the songs always end up being
really good
really good and I know that last season
I kind of struggled with being able to
figure out who was my favorite judge you
know because they're all so talented and
so wonderful but this season I have come
to the conclusion though it was
obviously hard it's like picking a
favorite child that Esther Dean is my
favorite judge I am obsessed with her
she like I'm obsessed with all of them
they're all so talented so it's not fair
to say but there's something about her
that is just so sweet and kind and just
like nice and I just want to be her
friend like I love her
my favorite is Ryan Tedder because I'm
just like such a Ryan Tedder girly but I
don't know if I spoke about this on the
toaster just like with you on FaceTime
but I only recently found out that
Esther Dean is in pitch perfect
she is the she's in all three movies and
I had literally no idea that it was her
she looks so different cuz she had like
a spiky like pixie cut yeah no people
times I knew it was her that was like a
fun thing that she did she's just so
versatile and it makes sense because I
think that snitches favorite judge is
Shane McNally so we're all like
represented oh good I just love like one
the persons done singing and then they
all just like riff off the song it's
like five seconds they create a whole
new song it's actually crazy
yeah s3d was sharing like a really
interesting kid because sometimes when
they're in the songwriting room instead
of like when you don't have the lyrics
yeah but you don't you but you just have
the melody you just sing like and she
was saying like she was she accidentally
did that when she was sharing the song
what's my name for Rihanna she's like oh
no no what's my name and they liked it
so much they kept it oh my god that's
fascinating isn't that fascinating yes
it is it's fascinating
Wow I love to fascinate you so I'd love
to be fascinated okay speaking of new
music ariana grande dangerously I'm
sorry about I'm sorry is this the story
speaking um of new music that's brought
to you by Hunter Killer yes oh thank god
I was so worried that it might not be
life can get so busy with kids work etc
we feel like we never get to spend
quality time with our family and friends
Hunter Killer is the new way to do game
night that gives us the opportunity
to have fun work together and
investigate crime without even having to
leave the house hunt a killer reinvents
the way we interact with murder
mysteries you can go from being a viewer
safe in the comfort of your own home to
be an investigator actively involved in
solving a case the latest season starts
with a woman Julia who unearthed the
corpse of a famous actress from the 30s
in her family's theater with the Board
of Directors trying to push Julia out
and the theaters reputation online you
will help solve this cold case
investigation before it's too late
with each delivery you'll sift through
piles of documents evidence audio
recordings and case files eliminating
suspects until you crack the case it
brings the fun of an escape room into
your home it's easy to play whether
you're solo or with family and friends
during this time you can even join their
spoiler-free online community that has
over over a hundred thousand members you
can share theories and help each out
help each other out along the way they
have over two thousand five star reviews
on Trustpilot so it's no wonder why
people love them so much
plus part of the proceeds for every box
goes to the Cold Case Foundation an
organization that is dedicated to
helping with real-life cold cases that's
fabulous I absolutely love hunter-killer
you know I like live for a game night
ordinarily but in the q games are just
really keeping me sane and hunting
cooler so new it's so fresh it's
fabulous I think a lot of people would
like it people who are really big fans
of like murder mystery and just like
murdery vibes I think they would love it
too especially I'm not like a murder
you know enthusiast but some people are
and I think they would love it as well
definitely it's a great thing to do
right now just for our listeners you can
go to Hunter Killer dot-com slash toast
and use the promo code toast a check out
for 20% off your first box head to hunt
a killer dot-com slash toast for 20% off
and to show your support for our podcast
that's hunt a killer calm slash toast
check it out that's something everyone
should be taken up in the queue sign on
hunt a killer okay thank you hunter
killer for bringing us this next story
which is honestly like really juicy
because ariana grande and Justin Bieber
released their new quarantine anthem
stuck with you and they released a music
video wherein Ari is confirming her
romance with Dalton gomez at the end of
the video the couple appears like in a
split screen with Justin and Haley and
she's like holding her man's hand so
she's obviously quarantining with her
new beau and I'm really
for her I was wondering if she was I
assumed that she was but you just never
know with her she just is always
throwing you a curveball and there's
like so much misinformation being spread
about her and I usually like hate these
like type of homegrown montage
Quarantine videos like they make me sad
but I don't know the Scooter Braun
machine was like in full effect because
there was so much going on in this music
video and they had a million fans and
then also a million celebrities like
stitched together that I was like it's
not a real couple or Zach what if
Paltrow and Brad Falchuk and here and in
hey was whether ouch Paltrow and Pratt
fell Chuck also Demi Lovato was in there
confirming her relationship with her new
man they kissed in the video scooter and
his wife was in it um obviously Halley
and Justin and you had a really nice
look at their property they had a huge
backyard oh that is so nice also Mila
Kunis and Ashton Kutcher we're in it
it's it like there was so much going on
and it was actually really funny because
ariana grande was alone in the music
video for the most part she was like
making out with her dog and like pouring
wine and it was like kind of funny like
single girl problems like surrounded by
couples but then at the end like she
twirled into her man's arms so it was
funny and I liked getting the
confirmation but she was being really
cute in the beginning I will say there's
a part of me that's disappointed that
it's not Jim Carrey oh I mean a part of
me there's my whole body's disappointed
that it's not Jim Carrey yeah I guess
this like just puts this case to bed I
don't know if it was ever true but at
this current function in time Ariana and
Jim are not a couple very disappointing
yeah but I'm happy for her this guy
seems like a cutie and I'm glad that
she's like taking it public you know
yeah Steph Curry and his wife were in it
literally in order to see how many
celebrities were actually in it you
would have to watch it five times
because there was like five videos on at
once and then it would go back really
quickly I actually could not keep up and
I'm like that looks like LeBron James
but I don't think it was LeBron James
like there were so many people in it and
it's like Gwyneth Paltrow and Brad
Falchuk like sitting in their living
room dancing but like there's five other
videos around him I'm just like fans all
over the world so I was like it's not a
fan there was a Paltrow
it was it's actually good it was really
kind of brilliant marketing nice yeah
that's good I listened to it once so I
haven't got like a
feel for whether I love it or not people
are calling it you know the quarantine
anthem and um that spot has already been
taken by six feet apart but maybe it
could be live the you know the
quarantine anthems little sister you
know like it's not it's not necessarily
the quarantine anthem but it's a popular
song in quarantine know like the e-news
is calling it there the quarantine and
them because it is a song about
quarantine by the two most the biggest
recording artists in the world but it
was just like we already got one of
those so so yeah and six apart is a
better song not that the ariana grande
want isn't good but six feet apart is
just better it's incredible yeah
incredible but this was cute love having
something to watch you know even if it
was just three minutes I appreciate that
because time moves so [__] slow here
in quarantine and anything I could do to
occupy my time I am grateful for totally
okay next tour eight Kylie Jenner
addresses fan who asks its asks if all
she does is quote play dress up at home
so a fan tweeted at Kylie saying just
kind of general just play dress up
around her house and Kylie responded yes
Ted oh my god people are such [__]
like if you're gonna say something like
nasty about someone on Twitter and tag
them like your dick and you deserve
whatever you have coming to you yeah
honestly Kylie just dressing up around
her house is such a vibe and they feel
like she's inspiring other people
especially me too because I feel like
when I saw her last week with her glam
and her hair and her outfit it kind of
just inspired me to like get a little
bit more glam for the show even if it's
just putting on bronzer or highlighter
or something um and I feel like it's for
so many of her fans like makeup and glam
are their hobbies and when you're not
doing an inquiry like you're it's
something that you love they but you
don't have so I feel like she's actually
setting like a nice example know and
like the the joke here is that Kylie
pretty much just plays dress-up around
her house and became a billionaire
because of it yeah like she's always
been just playing dress-up around her
house but recently she's been like going
to the clubs and stuff and taking her
talents you know to restaurants and bars
and clubs in Palm Springs and other
places but she's always been a
stay-at-home Queen always and you know
when were
all currently stay-at-home Queens we
have to appreciate the og the woman who
did it first Kylie Jenner she never left
her house before quarantine her life is
exactly the same except that now she's
in a newer and bigger house she
obviously found the time to move during
quarantine and that just must be so
exciting for anyone who's moved like
right before quarantine or just
redecorated right before quarantine
you're just like in this whole new world
that's really the way to go yeah I mean
in quarantine I didn't redecorate or
anything but I got a new mattress and
it's truly like going to bed every night
it's like a whole new experience that's
really exciting it's like this it's the
small things in quarantine I mean
totally that's how I feel about my love
sac I just like move it around the house
and I feel like we've redecorated that's
what I feel about the ton the peloton
you know gotta love the times you know
it's so funny like two days ago we were
talking about air pods like they I'm
like I haven't charged mine in three
years literally i sat down to do the
toast so what'd you do i sat and charged
him for like five minutes I have a
lightning charger you know what that is
I'm assuming something I charged it
something faster than normal charger
yeah they like it's like the new one
it's like not USB it's so dumb but I put
the air pods in for five minutes and the
air pots themselves went from three to
80% but the charger is still charging
okay cool
glad to hear it um I have a fun fifth
and final story for you I love a fun
fifth and final story um
because there will be a new Breaking Bad
themed Monopoly game that will let you
play drug lord
our husbands are gonna be thrilled yeah
how exciting I mean to me monopolies
like the perfect game it doesn't really
need a rebrand but I love like a
limited-edition moment me too and edgy
new board game wants you to kick game
night up a few notches with miss a
Breaking Bad themed Monopoly game which
was quietly released last week will
likely have classic board game and TV
fans alike asking quote who asked for
this liberties the cult hit TV series
ran on AMC from 2008 to 2013 and
infamously revolved around a high school
chemistry teacher who turns to
manufacturing and selling
methamphetamine to secure his family's
future after he's diagnosed with lung
cancer
Wow aside from the
part I didn't know the rest of that I
didn't know he was a teacher do you
never watch Breaking Bad no that would
be a great thing for you to watch um in
terms of this Monopoly game seems very
random Breaking Bad is literally been
off the air since I was in high school I
just I get that they're still like a
cult following but it's like it hasn't
been long enough that it's like a show
that has like a huge legacy like if you
came out with a friends monopoly like
okay but like it's only been 10 years it
just seems really random and weird but
there's a lot of nerds around the
country who are really excited about
this myself included so I think this is
fabulous yeah and I think it's cool cuz
it's like definitely not family-friendly
cuz it's probably about drugs and so
it's just monopoly with an edge and I
think that's probably a new sensation
for Monopoly players like our husbands
yeah I think it's also a new sensation
to have a board game be around like
selling drugs it's kind of weird if you
think about it cuz board games are
supposed to be this like family-friendly
vibe
it kind of reminds me of when I tried to
buy code names and I accidentally bought
code names dark edition which is like
all dirty words and had like anal and
lube on it and it was like really [__]
worthy but it's so funny I think I
remember that they had that yeah damn
damn well this is cool I'll probably buy
it totally that's a good dig your
husband watch Breaking Bad I think that
mine did that's actually a really good
present for him I think that mine did as
well been like watches so many TV shows
and like never finishes them mostly
because like we start together and then
it's like he has a job and I like have
so much free time so I just like to
finish it like we started Hollywood
together last night and I'll probably
finish it without him today well that's
a great segue into our TV recap let's
start with real houses in New York
because that was the mandatory viewing
for last night Kardashians is over who
knew I guess it makes sense because they
gave us that preview for coming in
September but I just kind of held that
hope that that didn't mean that because
sometimes they do a midseason preview
but it's over for now which is fine
honestly I wanted to get back to Ugly
Betty anyway so we only have real houses
in New York and today's TV recap segment
is brought to you by Billy self-care and
routines are always important whatever
you're using to get ready for the day
should always make you feel amazing meet
Billy they've recreated everyday
essentials by delivering premium razors
and high-performing body care directly
to you with no pink tax no
to the drugstore and no breaking the
bank go to my Billy comm to get their
starter kit for just nine dollars that
includes their award-winning razor to
refill blades and a magnetic holder that
keeps your razor safe and dry between
uses the magnetic holder is an absolute
game changer and I'm not gonna lie I
thought I would put it up and like it
would fall a million times cuz it's like
in the shower and all the condensation
and it's not falling once it's I put it
up like three months ago maybe more no
it has not fallen once even though it
gets wet and they do send like backup
one so even if it were to fall which it
hasn't I'm safe Lily's already drink it
Billy is out to change more than the way
you shave they just released three
completely clean must-have products to
add to your routine which is a lip balm
a dry shampoo and face wipes that you
should definitely stock up for I use
Billy before they were a sponsor of the
toast because I'm cutting edge and my
sister Margot had one and it's just
everything of the sort Margot was like
this razor is gonna change your life I'm
like how it's a razor like how is it
different from all of their razors and
it just it's like you get a closer a
cleaner a better shave I have like
really irritable skin and especially on
my upper thighs and I don't find that
like I break out or I get razor burn
it's just a really fabulous razor and
the magnetic holder is just truly a life
and game changer totally I was dreading
shaving my armpits in the queue as you
know I tried to like wax them at home
and then I got my Billy razor and now
it's like I don't need to go back like
honestly it's such a close shave it's
nice go to my Billy comm to meet the
razor that made everyone start talking
about razors they're an allure best of
beauty winner and on nylons beauty hit
list for a reason to express a little up
for our show go to my Billy dot-com
slash toast it's a small way you can
support the show while getting the best
razor you'll ever own
it's just nine dollars to get your
starter kit plus free shipping always go
to my Billy dot-com slash toasts and
that spelled my bi ll e kind of like
Eilish bi l li ye my Billy comm slash
toast you don't want to miss out on the
razor of a lifetime i need to send one
to dana and Diggy see do you guys see
that picture the kosher took the
internet by storm
she broke the internet she needs a Billy
razor like that's a nice gift for her
yeah for sure it's a nice gift for her
fiance um okay Real Housewives of New
York what are your thoughts my thoughts
are once again the episode just made me
sad
like this is what New York has come to
but at the same time that event while it
was deeply problematic and we'll get
into it that bar looks super funny I
never heard of it slave oh I totally
agree when they were going down the
slide I was like oh this is fun I love
that all the women are doing it even
though they're wearing like short skirts
and white pants but like it's probably
so new that the side is still clean so
while I appreciate Luann's you know
wanting to be philanthropic Ramona
senior really said it best like it was
all over the place it was like an
anti-bullying charity but then also a
podcast and then there was like another
philanthropic sponsor like it was just
very confusing as to what it actually
was and to be honest I was really sad
for the comedians who agreed to do it
because I'm sure some of them were like
good um but like the vibe of the show
was like it was a long long kind of
event even though I'm sure some of them
like did a good job
um I just felt bad that like they
thought they were gonna like have their
comedy special on Bravo and then they
just got made fun of like I really felt
sad about that yeah the whole thing was
very sad and my favorite part was when
Jacques Assam if they've ever bullied
others and they do the flashback to
every time they believe someone on the
show and then they say no no I've never
and that really made it all worth it for
me I've really been liking shock when he
and LuAnn had lunch I thought like he
was being such a good friend like
getting good advice and I feel at this
point the common consensus is that LuAnn
isn't an alcoholic like she was going
through a rough time and she made really
bad choices um so all of her friends
trying to get her back on her feet is
kind but then we need to talk about
Elyse because I guess she's becoming a
housewife she had an interview yes and I
think she's going she's going on the
wine trip next week like housewives
sponsored trip oh I feel like she's
gonna be a friend of housewife I don't
think she'll be kind of house Mike this
season
I think she'll become one next season
yeah but they're like grooming her
whereas when I saw her at all the like
everywhere in the Hamptons I was just I
never thought that she was I need to
know more about this woman you know I
don't live for her but it's my
understanding that she's very wealthy
and that's really what this show could
use because if you think about it they
don't film in any of the women's
apartments anymore because they all just
live in like sad apartments like they
live in rentals that are like small
and like people it's just like it's not
this aspirational show anymore um Ramona
moved Sonia moved
Dorinda moved and we got a little peek
at leas apartment and it's just like not
what you would expect from a New York
City housewife and we need some money
and so if Elise he's gonna bring that I
don't care how annoying she is like we
need money yeah I actually I agree with
that um we can I see something about
Jacques that I wanted to say yeah I love
him and I really feel like LuAnn was at
her finest like housewife person mom
human when she was with Jacques I think
that was like a really good relationship
and I love that they've stayed in touch
um and something that a lot of people
might not have understood or noticed
because she looked so different is the
podcast host who was hosting the event
now she non-city she was on princesses
Long Island which was a terrible show on
Bravo that was a disgrace towards
princesses and people from Long Island
and most importantly Jax but she was on
it yeah and you wouldn't know that
because they never they just kept saying
Chanel in the city in Chanel um and then
I like looked her up cuz obviously like
a fellow podcaster I'm like what is this
podcast and her name is chanel Amar'e
and I would recognize that name anywhere
from princesses of Long Island exactly
so I think that was like a misstep that
they did - a flashback to a princesses
Long Island moment but didn't did it
make the connection and I just wanted to
make sure that everyone knew I don't
even know what happened in episode up
until the event Oh Sonja going to
Englewood and hearing about the losses
of I can't use another word other than
sad like it was pathetic like I wanted
to cry yeah also um Dorinda visiting her
old haunts her old house going to Nelo
and something's going on that food
looked insanely good I was dying and
literary text my friends like we have to
go to nella like it looked so good and
you know what I kind of was living for
like Dorinda being like the classy old
broad she used to be she looked fabulous
like her tweed coat and all of her
jewelry I kind of loved that yeah um I
don't know I feel like maybe I wonder
why she went that day it felt to me like
maybe it was rich
it's birthday or something or some sort
of anniversary but we didn't get any
context like that and so instead like
her walking in front of her old house
and like talking to herself basically
even though we know there's like
cameramen there like if you just saw a
woman like talking at her house um you
could think she's crazy no you're like
there's the crazy lady again talking to
buildings or like if you live in that
housing you're like oh my god the former
tenant is here talking at us look out
the window someone startled II know it
was strange we didn't get enough context
that's her sure I just thought she
looked glamorous like she's become like
kind of edgy she's like wearing her hair
spiky and like metallic clothes so I
just loves like an Upper East Side lady
luncheon look for her I think that the
more that they show the woman's past and
former lives um
the more sad the the present is it's
when it comes to Dorinda now I didn't
even include her on that club before
Dorinda Tinsley Sonja even LuAnn who
went from being a countess and married
to account to the comedy event disgrace
yeah
disgrace um one other thing that I
wanted to mention was what did I want to
mention [__] wait there was something
yeah
Oh Tinsley um first of all that whole
storyline about her and Dorinda like if
I have to hear them fight one more time
like I'm actually gonna turn my TV TV
off I don't care but um I definitely
feel like there's something weird with
this whole Bruce thing he seems like an
imaginative imaginative boyfriend like
he's there and then he's not and then
they're together and then ah and it's
just like it's very possible that this
man bursts does not exist oh I'm sure
that he does but I feel like I don't I
don't I didn't meet him I don't care
about him what Tinsley's mother said um
about how like she is a woman with our
children now she's gonna want all these
things like honestly that was the best
advice her mother has ever given her
because it was straight-up fast like a
man with a million children in the
million ex-wives like doesn't need
another wife and more children like he's
done totally and it's just like each
to a person whatever it is that they're
going through like just made me sad like
the tinsley of it all the dorinda of it
all the Sonia Englewood like everyone's
storylines was just so sad to me the
highlight of the episode was the land
taking a drink
um because I got what she meant it's
like she's obviously not gonna get drunk
but it's like once you cross the line
it's like it's not a thing anymore so I
kind of agreed with her mentality just
have a sip of vodka um
Dorinda was like cheering her on like
too much and that's what Elyse was
saying but at least like this is not
your business get the [__] out no but I
think it seems as though Elyse is a good
friend of the group somehow just we've
never seen her on the show before
um and what during the was doing didn't
alarm me at all until Olli said it I was
like oh yeah actually like I don't know
and I feel like actually Ramona's
reaction was the best reaction because
she was a supportive of LuAnn drinking
whatever but she's also a little
skeptical yeah and I'm loving the
friendship between Ramona and Lea same
the maternal vibes I think that airs
opposites
yeah there's such opposites and it
really works and I like Ramona's not
really one to go for like the new young
girl but I think there's just something
about Lea that makes her so likable to
everyone and they can't help they can't
help themselves
yeah I agree I like the friendship the
respect they picked him each other up in
the car I was living for that that
moment logistical II though that makes
no sense because it looks to me like Lea
doesn't just live downtown like she
lives in side-eye that's what I thought
too
Ramona lives on the Upper East Side so
unless the event was I feel like the
event was in Midtown then that doesn't
make any sense that they picked either
up so I agree okay so that's that on
that um I'll just talk really quickly
about Hollywood I only watch the first
two episodes and I won't spoil anything
it's just like I didn't know I like
watching things when I don't know what
they're about um and obviously it's like
about Hollywood in the 50s maybe I want
to say um I don't know time periods and
I just liked that I had no idea
obviously it's like someone's trying to
make it in Hollywood I just didn't know
like what route they were gonna take and
to me like please don't show us the
route because I'm not
I'm not what this show I think is gonna
be it's so not what I expected
so that's a part that I really liked
about it I do feel like there's so much
sex it's like it's hard to focus
sometimes there's just like a million
sex scenes in every episode and I love a
good sex scene not I think it's like a
little oversaturated with the sex scenes
maybe they just wanted to like start out
strong and it'll fizzle out like Game of
Thrones like it was literally so much
incest every single episode and then
there was like never another incest
again
so we'll see it's just like it's a
little distracting okay that's a fair
assessment I'm gonna watch out this
weekend along with our the Ugly Betty
and I think I'm not going into Episode
seven of Ugly Betty so if you are
interested in like watching along with
me I'll recap like bulk episodes I think
that would be a fun thing if you've been
looking for a great great show it is so
good it has so much heart such good
storylines like the fashion the insults
its iconic um and as your character and
for us to do uh my favorite character
growing up my favorite character was
Amanda I think but like now be watching
it she's so mean
it hurts me like I think as an adult
like I realized what so much that's
wrong with her there's so much it's
right with her too and every once in a
while like she has like a very real
moment but the meanness outweighs
honestly you know what I love Hilda I
love Betty sister she's so fabulous and
she just like is too like she just
doesn't give a damn and she's oh no I'm
sorry my favorite character Justin Hilda
son it's Justin oh my god right and by
the way like he needs to be
editor-in-chief of mode like every
assessment that he has on the magazine
or the fashion it is on point he
literally is a better editor than
Wilhemina Slater who by the way I
absolutely love Wilhelmina like she is
just a hard-working Queen and we have no
choice but to stand and if you were
passed up for editor-in-chief job when
you've been carrying this magazine on
your back I think they could make a show
that's a Wilhelmina Slater origin story
and we'd be rooting for her to take down
Daniel Meade this nepotistic know
nothing little [__]
even though ultimately I do like Daniel
because he's a friend to Betty but he is
so undeserving like
Dustin is by far the best character and
to me he's such an iconic actor because
he was also in that very important
episode of Suite Life of Zack and Cody
and he's the kid who sings I've got beef
between my teeth it would be lost if I
had floss and he's just an icon yeah
also in a sixth episode Debi Mazar is in
it there's just so many good actors in
it Alan Dale so you know Caleb Nichol /
Anders from dynasty plays Bradford Meade
Judith Light plays his wife just like
the casting is so on point and I
remember down the road that Hilda starts
dating Eddie Cibrian just everyone is
there
Oh selma hayek plays read the new
magazine that Eddie Cibrian relationship
with Hilda is like one of them most
important parts of the show I know and
you know what if it wasn't for Ugly
Betty and I would never know who Eddie
Cibrian was and so that was also the
same time I think was like around 2010
when Brandi Glanville was on Beverly
Hills and I had context about what she
was talking about and who I be Cyprian
was because I watched Ugly Betty
do you remember what happens with hilda
and Eddie Cibrian they date don't I
don't want to know like all I know I
think I think he's like Justin's gym
coach or something I don't know I won't
say anything else but when you get there
it's like so iconic can't wait I'm so
excited for you that sounds so fun
Thanks I think we have a meeting in one
minute
so okay you have to hop off thank you
guys so much for listening to the money
trust money morning show or we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so it Spotify
iTunes stitcher Public Radio I already
know Cass box all the places so ever you
listen to podcast find us the morning
totalling five star view about a
beautiful stunning it smart we are have
an amazing weekend you guys we will see
you on Monday
have a great weekend bye